favi risponde inizia il video con
l'altro fabi bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuto io sono famigie anch'io sono
fa vincere
chi siamo dovevo dire no dovevo io
dovevo dire io io io bella tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti che sono video sono fatti j
prima di grigia ragazzi come al solito
di ripartire la fa latte la settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
benedetta che ha fatto sto disegno
bellissimo soprattutto la faccia di
chiamare stupenda ma tra l'altro il mio
ciuffo ma perché i suoi capelli che
manca gare anche nella vita reale ma dio
mio almeno non delle fan art gesù
ragazzi ieri passare alle news che
allora da prima notizia ragazzi molti
dopo questa molti si succederanno però
pace all'anima loro quando è andata a
los angeles ragazzi avevo detto che
sarei tornato in america per il blitz
con che sarebbe una fiera di videogiochi
eccolo capri 20 questa se ci vado questa
settimana che viene da lunedì a domenica
sono in america sono ad anaheim in
california
mi sento troppo un figo pronunciare
parole inglesi non so perché comunque
ragazzi sono in america questa settimana
e comunque quando vado in america faccio
un altro blog in cui ho fatto visto che
vi abita tipo adorato fino alla morte
blog a los angeles varò un altro blog vi
sarà epico anche stavolta per farmi
perdonare di questa cosa bruttissima
domani ragazzi che domenica oro nei live
streaming qui su youtube
dalle 6 in poi nella quale ragazzi
giocherò con voi in diretta sarà una
cosa fantastica anche perché aveva fatto
l'anno scorso è stato etico per il 20
ragazzi ho scelto due giochi che
giocheremo insieme sarà veramente
fantastico perché lo faremo in diretta
apparire chi vuole partecipare apparire
nel video di uno chagall tra ragazzi a
partecipare vi lascio il link dei giochi
in descrizione ovviamente sono grati
perché ho fatto in modo che chiunque
potesse partecipare se ve li scaricato
adesso ragazzi ce l'avete già quindi
domani sarete i primi a partecipare
contro di me sono anche le istruzioni
per scaricarli descrizione mainas france
cento rea non dovrei neanche metterle
perché è veramente semplice quindi
ragazzi per chi se li scarica domani
potrà sfidarmi in diretta perché fa lo
vide in diretta e mi ha intrigato tanto
vinco io perché non c'è sfida un'ultima
cosa poi la pianto con le news perché lo
so che si travasano i maroni così e ne
avete letto tutti quanti che sono andato
al tg1
davvero non lo sapevo neanch'io di
essere andato al tg1 grazie di avermelo
detto è stata una cosa veramente strana
vedermi lì la sera solo che cos'è quel
cos'è qualcosa ragazzi in quegli spunti
un orecchio da d'acqua questo queste
ragazzine che possono chiudere qui con
le news quindi non vi spaventate dalla
prossima settimana non farci uscire
video ma perché sono in america poi
riprendo a bomba invece sono vani volete
partecipare alla live che faccio domani
in diretta a giocare con me scaricate i
giochi nella descrizione che ci mettete
due secondi e dopo di gesso ammazziamo
fino alla morte io io e te proprio io io
e te mi piace mi sento un maniaco quando
faccio ste faccia perfetto lega anche
oggi i parchi quotidiani ci sono tra
l'altro prima cosa ragazzi perché mi
avete inviato un kebab i mutui per che
cos'è questo coso direi ripartire da
questo lega perché mi sembra tipo è
stato pesa un quintale vorrei capire che
cosa accade l'effetto ragazzo troppo dei
cos'è questo cos'è questo coso cioè mi
avete inviato dei dei documenti tipo
hicks files
[Musica]
fenicotteri fenicotteri fenicotteri
qualcuno ha voglia di spiegarmi perché
ma perché
ma perché il sesso di questa cosa quale
oltre a questo ragazzi c'è ovviamente la
la nutella perché non poteva mancare
ovviamente già anche finita grazie
comunque
comunque la foto dei fenicotteri e ha
vinto tutto tutto deve riuscire a fare 1
scartato decente anche stato porca put a
ogni volta ma va porchia vai a casa
questa è una figata pazzesca questi
occhiali vincono qualsiasi cosa nel
mondo proprio ovviamente via delle
caramelle tir in gara ti ringrazio da
morire perché queste sono troppo buono o
mio dio altri caramelle ma basta mi
ascolta ti presento io poi il mio
dentista e non perché c'è non ci capiamo
e poi c'è un orsacchiotto che è troppo
gnocco secondo me ragazzine che le
caramelle erano per lui non per me però
vi ringrazio di cuore s fa via prè
impacco c'è il tuo videogame preferito
gt gt in gta un altro gt a mineo 26 dtt
a basta fatemi aprire il soccorso che
devo capire un attimo cosa ma c'è una
manna ma gta 5 da gta 5
[Musica]
se ci sono già però quindi non ne ho uno
non ne ho due ma ben tre gta 5 grandi
razzi di cui grazie anche c'è anche
killzone killzone 3
killzone 2 e chi il sono uno show la
saga di vidzone senza averli neanche
comprati grazie e poi sempre al turismo
pro una donna 200 euro di videogiochi in
un pacco poster un poster di wolverine
ovviamente perché un auricolare ragazzi
di quelli che usano la cina infatti è
molto professionale la caccia anche
scritto topolino qua sopra quindi c'è
questo questo è proprio da james mondo
una targa con su scritto buon natale
anche se mi mancano tipo tre mesi no due
mesi due mesi la minchia cazzo lo fa
regali detto questo ragazzi non vedono
novi io non ho visto una sega perché
questi occhiali non si vedeva una mazza
di niente direi che possiamo passare al
fa vi risponde gemelli da foursquare nel
fare risponde five driver foto più
divertente che c'è da piccola ho dire
perché perché io io ho scelto questo
perchè la seconda domanda arriva da wake
jacques fa vi risponde qual è la cosa
più strana che un una fan ha fatto per
te sbucciate ci sarà da ridere ci sarà
da ridere da beck reding anno esatto fa
mi chiamo ricordo precisamente rom era
ad una fiera alla ragazza mi aveva
riconosciuto alla lontano ea urlata
dalla fiera era piena zeppa di gente era
troppo pieno non riusciva a camminare
c'era un fracasso allucinante a un certo
punto una tizia da un chilometro grida
mi chiama vince gelo lo grida proprio ai
quattro venti tutti si sono zittiti c'è
ma roba che non riuscire a sentire
nemmeno quello che ti parlava di fianco
finché non c'è una un chilometro ha
urlato talmente tanto che tutti si sono
zittiti si sono tutti tutti sono rimasti
così questa qui mi vede inizia a correre
verso di me mi arriva davanti
s'inginocchia fa così davanti a tutti
c'è stata una io ero tipo ok non mi
guardate non mie gare sta scherzando
alzati alzati cazzo è stato è stato
assurdo poi ragazzi più avanti non ha
trovato bene racconta un'altra che è
stata anche questa epica però ve la
racconto più avanti questa cosa
veramente strana marco zanelli fa degli
swan the molto computer un transformer
no optimus calmo tim brown zio bravo
quindi ragazzine che posso concludere
qui video di oggi ricordati a chi
volesse giocare domani contro di me live
giochi che faccio li trovate in
descrizione anche come scaricarli giorno
scritto come fare una cazzata i primi
che se lo scaricano in gioco mi
aggiungono agli amici che ovviamente
sono fa vj musivi accetto e poi l'invito
che appena faccia la live sarà
fantastico questori e che forse un cazzo
mica mi sono ricordata la fa vi
domandate culo poi domanda regala qual è
il posto che vorreste visitare così
almeno ci vado e faccio un blog quello
più votato ragazzi lo giuro lo farò
lo giuro non mi venite a dire antartide
che vado lì e che poi soffro di freddo e
crepe i rialzi se il video è piaciuto ma
solito lasciato argomento mi piace anche
a pagina di facebook e come nei video
tratte nella descrizione serve ore si
distintivi ci rimettiamo al prossimo
video quelle ragazze